[Musique]
vous voulez toujours sur Triple 7 oui
commandant de bord le courrier depuis
deux ans c'est bien ça comment tu vas
bien
vous dormez correctement en escale oui
vous récupérez facilement
oui j'adore ce style de vie depuis la
dernière fois des événements importants
dans votre vie personnelle non bonjour
Estelle
elle est rentrée dans ta vie à 20 ans à
la tour ravagée et elle a foutu le camp
je sais pas comment font les gens pour
oublier
la plupart mettent tout dans des
terroirs à venir et il ferme à clé
[Musique]
Anna
comme les inventer des histoires
horribles plutôt qu'à mettre qu'on s'est
trompé sur tout
ça fait 10 jours qu'elle a disparu
apparemment quelqu'un l'aurait vu à
Tokyo
depuis deux ans c'est bien ça
vous dormez correctement en escale pays
[Musique]
vous récupérez facilement
depuis la dernière fois des événements
importants dans votre vie personnelle
rien qui puisse vous perturber ou
stresser